so the fetterman Dr Oz debate just ended  holy smokes full-blown 30 car Amtrak  derailment for fetterman here he is  explaining how he'd handle inflation  here's what I think we have to find  about inflation here right now that's  what we need to fight about inflation  you know right now because it's a tax on  Working Families you know and Dr Oz  can't possibly understand what that is  like  oh it gets better if that guy's elected  senator from the state of Pennsylvania  you'll have real concerns about the  system being legitimate subscribe to the  Fox News YouTube channel to catch our  nightly opens stories that are changing  the world and changing your life from  Tucker Carlson tonight